Donald Trump has done what I call an
insta flip Donald Trump is making it
very clear that he has completely
bamboozled his supporters the trumpeters
have been completely bamboozled into
supporting a guy who is not going to do
a ton of what he told them he was going
to do during his presidential campaign
Donald Trump must have pledged hundreds
probably thousands of times that he is
going to repeal Obamacare the Affordable
Care Act tons of his supporters when
asked at campaign rallies and during
interviews what do you like the most
about Trump policy-wise many of them
couldn't put together any answer but the
ones that could would say I like that
he's going to repeal the Affordable Care
Act Obamacare and on that note Donald
Trump has now done what I am calling an
insta flip within hours of being elected
president of the United States right
after his meeting with President Obama
he said you know what lots of those
provisions in Obamacare which I've been
saying is a disaster and we're going to
get rid of they're pretty good
provisions and I'm gonna keep them he's
going to keep the ban on insurers
denying coverage for pre-existing
conditions that is a major change
created by the Affordable Care Act told
the Wall Street Journal he also likes
the idea of keeping young adults up to
age 26 on their parents policies if they
want to be a major component of the
Affordable Care Act saying quote I like
those very much Pat Obamacare is a
disaster it must go it is terrible in
every way I like a lot of these
provisions very much and I plan to keep
them will his supporters ever realize
that they have been bamboozled they
probably will start to but it's honestly
good news I mean a year ago Trump went
on 60 minutes and said that everyone
needed to be taken care of under some
sort of health care plan yeah and that
the government would pay for it but we
would save so much money on the other
end honestly if we were going to get
some sort of Republican out of this
election sure Trump is a demagogue and
there's so many things to go after him
on yeah he's honestly willing to
compromise on some things and this is
one of them I am increasingly thinking
that unless pence gets to him and more
than likely I'll tell you later Pence is
going to be running the show here that's
that's probably the reality and that's
horrible but these are provisions that
most people like a lot we know from
polling if you
before and during the passage of the
Affordable Care Act when people were
asked what's your opinion of this
provision without saying this is part of
Obamacare this is a communist takeover
of health care do you like this
provision these provisions were very
very popular and there's a very good
chance that Donald Trump could repeal
Obamacare by name create something new
which is very similar to it and say hey
I did it
it's true it's from care and then his
supporters without having the capacity
to realize well it's it's called
something else so it must be different
they would say hey Trump did it he
repealed it we won again America is now
great well it really is amazing if you
ask people what they think about health
care coverage being allowed to deny
patients based on pre-existing
conditions overwhelmingly unpopular
absolutely people being able to stay on
their parents health care until they're
26 is widely popular and mandating that
companies with over 50 employees have to
provide health care coverage for their
employees also very popular but when you
ask about Obama care overall they say
they don't want it yeah now we don't
like that at all this is also about you
know what what we're going to see in
terms of who has Trump's ear because he
said this pretty closely pretty shortly
after speaking to President Obama and by
all reports he was totally shell-shocked
by that meeting we'll talk about that
later but Trump often just thinks what
the last person said to him is the best
thing if 10 minutes after saying this to
the Wall Street Journal
Steve Bannon or rinse pre visco hey by
the way that's bad stuff we don't want
those things all of a sudden that's
Trump's new position we have to remember
that Trump often just goes with it it's
like a little kid and attention-deficit
and just very very pliable mind we're
the last thing someone told him is the
best idea and that's so concerning
because as president you're gonna have
so many people in your ear you're gonna
have so many voices to choose from yeah
and if you just go with the last person
I mean that's really not the way to go
it's not exactly the way to run a
country and we'll talk later about the
fact that Trump is clearly completely
confused and bewildered by what the job
of president is and that's not a good
confusion realization to have days after
you've been elected president of the
United States let's take a break what a
weekend of news and we've got all of it
for you coming up Warby Parker is
offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing